.
Hopp! Kommt! Nach Hause gehen!
Die Kühe auf dem Eichenmoos-Hof
im luzernischen Büron
haben ein schönes Leben.
Laue Sommernächte wie diese
verbringen sie auf der Weide.
Die haben hier
das Paradies auf Erden.
Noch nicht, aber bald.
- Was heisst das?
Sie müssen bald
keine Milch mehr geben
und dürfen einfach so sein,
wie sie sind:
Kuh sein, fressen, schlafen.
Sie dürfen die Kälber behalten.
Komm, Lenny!
Komm! Komm jetzt, hopp!
Die Tage der Eichenmoos-Kühe
als Nutztiere sind gezählt.
Wie aus einem Bauernhof -
mit Amors Unterstützung -
ein Lebenshof wird,
davon handelt dieser Film.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Komm, Alessia!
Seit vier Generationen wird hier,
auf dem Eichenmoos-Hof in Büron,
gemolken.
Doch bald ist Schluss -
Betriebsleiter Beat Troxler
steigt aus der Milchwirtschaft aus.
Aus ethischen Gründen.
Eine Kuh
ist eigentlich ein Spitzensportler.
Sie muss ...
Sie produziert den ganzen Tag Milch.
Der ganze Kreislauf der Kuh
läuft immer auf Hochtouren.
Und das merkt man den Kühen auch an,
gerade nach dem Abkalben.
Dann kommt es vor,
dass sie in ein Defizit fallen
und man den Tierarzt braucht
oder Ähnliches.
Ich erhoffe mir, dass es das Tier
nachher wirklich schöner hat,
wenn es
keine Leistung mehr bringen muss.
Es waren ein Kälbchen und eine Kuh
wie diese,
welche die Neuausrichtung
zum Lebenshof eingeläutet haben.
Einmal wurde in der Nacht
im Laufstall ein Kalb geboren.
Es war schon einige Stunden
mit der Mutter zusammen
und hat auch schon
bei der Mutter getrunken.
Am Morgen gingen wir in den Stall,
haben das gesehen
und haben wie üblich
das Kalb von der Mutter getrennt.
Die Mutter wurde ziemlich wütend.
Wir mussten wirklich schauen,
dass sie nicht auf uns losgeht.
Wir brachten das Kalb ins Iglu.
Dann verweigerte es die Nahrung.
Wir versuchten es mit dem Eimer,
mit dem Schoppen, mit allem,
aber es hat nicht mehr getrunken.
Dann mussten wir es zwei Tage direkt
mit der Sonde in den Magen ernähren,
damit es nicht starb.
Ich dachte dann für mich:
Es läuft so falsch!
Es hätte bei der Mutter
so gut funktioniert
und dann kommen wir
und nehmen ihr das Kalb weg.
Nur, damit wir Menschen
die Milch trinken können,
die für das Kalb bestimmt ist.
Kühe geben nur Milch,
wenn sie Kälber gebären.
Auf konventionellen Höfen
wachsen die Kälber darum
ohne ihre Mütter in Iglus auf,
zusammen mit anderen Kälbern.
Auf dem Eichenmoos-Hof dürfen
die Kälber bei ihren Müttern bleiben.
Das fühlt sich viel besser an.
Es ist auch viel schöner,
wenn man in den Stall kommt,
das Kalb bei der Mutter ist
und das Ganze funktioniert.
Für die Kühe
ist es sicher auch schöner.
Das Herz öffnet sich,
wenn man das macht.
220'000 kg Milch pro Jahr
liefern die 26 Kühe
und sichern den Eichenmoos-Bauern so
ihr bescheidenes Einkommen.
Doch neben den ethischen gibt es auch
handfeste finanzielle Gründe
für die Umstrukturierung.
Man kann davon leben,
aber ich sehe, dass die Preisspirale
stetig bergab gehen wird.
Wenn man uns mit dem Ausland und
dessen Milchpreisen vergleicht ...
Wenn sich das anpassen wird,
bin ich
mit dem hohen Arbeitsaufwand -
weil wir viel von Hand machen -
nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig.
Mein Ziel ist, dass es
einen fliessenden Übergang gibt.
Wir suchen ja für jede Kuh
eine Patenschaft.
Sodass sie durch die Patenschaft
so viel Geld erwirtschaftet
wie sie mit der Milchproduktion
erwirtschaftet hat.
Je mehr Kühe Paten haben,
desto eher können wir
aus der Milchproduktion aussteigen.
* Muhen *
Das Konzept wird sein,
dass wir den Unterhalt der Tiere
aus Patenschaften generieren können.
Und unser Einkommen
käme aus der Pflanzenmilch,
in deren Produktion wir sehr
wahrscheinlich einsteigen können.
Aber dann sind Sie
keine richtigen Bauern mehr.
Nein, aber das ist
auch nicht schlimm, oder?
Ich würde nicht sagen,
kein richtiger Bauer mehr.
Denn schlussendlich
bleiben der Ackerbau
und der Futterbau für die Tiere
genau gleich bestehen.
Wir müssen die Pflanzenmilch
auch produzieren,
das gehört auch zur Landwirtschaft.
Wir verarbeiten ja schlussendlich
unsere eigenen Produkte.
Und die Betreuung der Tiere
gehört auch zur Landwirtschaft,
der Bauer
ist ein Betreuer von Tieren.
* Akzentuierte
gezupfte Saitenklänge *
Bis später, Schatz.
- Bis später.
Der Hafer für den hofeigenen
Pflanzendrink ist schon angesät.
Im nächsten Frühling wird geerntet.
Jedes Tier auf dem Eichenmoos-Hof
trägt einen Namen.
Jedes Tier
wird als Individuum angesehen.
Und kein Tierleben
ist hier mehr wert als ein anderes.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Ja, genau, Rafi.
Das ist Beauty.
Sie wurde kurz vor Ostern
von einem Velofahrer angefahren.
Sie hatte beide Beine gebrochen.
Eines war offensichtlich gebrochen,
es hing richtig hinunter.
Wir gingen mit ihr nach Sursee
in die Kleintierchirurgie.
Dort haben sie sie operiert.
Jetzt kann sie wieder gehen.
Ich wollte ihr
diese Chance einfach geben.
Als ich sie angesehen
und ihr in die Augen geschaut habe,
konnte ich sie nicht einfach ...
Klar, wenn es geheissen hätte,
das werde nie wieder gut
und sie leide nur noch,
wäre es klar gewesen.
Dann hätten wir sie erlösen müssen.
Aber solange es die Möglichkeit gab,
ihr zu helfen,
hatte ich das Gefühl,
ich sei ihr das schuldig.
Bei meinem Hund oder meiner Katze
würde ich es ja auch so machen.
Und so ist Beauty -
nach einer 700-fränkigen Operation -
wohl eines der wertvollsten Hofhühner
des Landes.
Bei der Umstellung
vom Milchbetrieb zum Lebenshof
werden die Eichenmoos-Bauern
von Sarah Heiligtag unterstützt.
Seit drei Jahren begleitet und berät
die Philosophin und Landwirtin
Bauern wie die Troxlers, die aus der
Nutztierhaltung aussteigen wollen.
Jede Woche erhält sie
drei bis fünf neue Anfragen.
Ich denke, hier ist es ideal,
weil sich
zwei sehr unterschiedliche Menschen
gefunden haben,
die es gemeinsam machen können,
mit ihren Fähigkeiten und Talenten.
Beide haben ein Herz für die Sache
und ein Verständnis dafür,
was es braucht.
Und natürlich der Ort,
der Hof an sich und die Stallungen,
die man super
dafür vorbereiten kann,
und die ganze Situation
der Gegebenheiten.
All das zusammen ist ideal.
Man muss nichts erfinden,
um etwas Tolles daraus zu machen.
Lebenshöfe sind angewiesen
auf Menschen,
die Patenschaften
für Nutztiere übernehmen,
ohne dafür einen konkreten Gegenwert
zu erhalten.
Er ist auch jetzt
abhängig von Personen,
die die Produkte kaufen,
die er jetzt verkauft,
und von den Direktzahlungen,
die tragen, was er jetzt verkauft.
Man muss definieren,
was Abhängigkeit bedeutet,
das ist eine wichtige Frage.
Grob gesagt
verkauft er jetzt Produkte,
für die ein Tier sterben musste,
nachher verkauft er
eine Dienstleistung,
bei der das Tier leben darf.
Das ist ein Teil,
er wird noch andere Dinge verkaufen.
Aber es ist Teil einer Vision
eines friedlichen Zusammenlebens
von Mensch und Tier.
Das ist etwas viel Grösseres
als ein Liter Milch.
Seid ihr ready
für einen Tag der offenen Tür 2020?
Ist das überhaupt so?
- Ja.- Ja, sicher.
Bis dahin sollten wir die Rinder
im Saustall untergebracht haben.
Das wäre ein Ziel.
Laufstallumbau ...
Ich weiss nicht, ob wir
bis dann schon etwas machen können.
Bis Ende Jahr
werden noch acht Kälber geboren.
Damit keines mehr den Hof verlassen
muss, werden Umbauarbeiten nötig.
Die ganze Fläche des Stalls wird
nachher ein Laufstall für die ...
* Muhen *
... Kühe.
Dort haben dann 33 Stück Platz.
Ich schätze, dass schlussendlich
200'000-300'000 Fr.
an Umbaukosten entstehen,
bis wir den Lebenshof
wirklich haben.
Wir haben noch eine Hypothek,
die wir auslösen könnten,
die wir für den Bau brauchen können.
Sollte das nicht reichen,
würden wir schauen,
ob wir mit Stiftungen oder Gönnern
Geld generieren könnten
oder mit einem Crowdfunding
oder Ähnlichem.
Neben den Milchkühen hält
Beat Troxler auch 200 Mastschweine.
Ab sofort
kauft er keine neuen Tiere mehr dazu,
der Stall wird sich so in den
nächsten Wochen immer mehr leeren.
Was ist mit dem Schwein mit
dem blauen Streifen auf dem Rücken?
Wir haben sie gewogen
und sie wiegt über 100 kg.
Sie wird nächsten Donnerstag
in den Schlachthof gebracht.
Ja. Es ist so:
Wenn sie über 100 kg schwer sind,
melde ich sie am Mittwoch an
und eine Woche später
kommen sie in den Schlachthof.
* Verspielte glockige Musik *
Mitte August
fährt der letzte Lastwagen
mit diesen Schweinen
in den Schlachthof.
Den Troxlers fehlt der Platz,
um die Tiere auf dem Hof zu behalten.
Und sie brauchen den Erlös für den
Umbau der Stallungen für die Kühe.
Prioritäten setzen
auf einem angehenden Lebenshof.
Zwei Schweine aber dürfen bleiben -
für immer: Felix und Nala.
Komm, Felix, komm!
- Komm, Felix, komm!
Denn mit Felix hat die Geschichte
von Claudia und Beat
ihren Anfang genommen.
Fein sitzen. Ja, super!
Lecker, nicht?
Es geschah vor fünf Jahren.
Felix, der heute gut und gerne
300 kg auf die Waage bringt,
war damals drei Monate alt
und 25 kg schwer.
Ich habe Felix
unten im Maststall gesehen.
Er hatte irgendwie
so spezielle Augen.
Ich habe mich etwas in ihn verliebt
und wollte nicht,
dass er geschlachtet wird.
Also fragte ich,
ob ich ihn kaufen und retten dürfe.
Was haben Sie gedacht,
als diese Frau fragte,
ob sie dieses Schwein
auf einen Gnadenhof bringen dürfe?
Ich fand es schön,
dass jemand auch mal anders denkt.
Ich war einverstanden damit.
Ich habe kein Problem gesehen und
auch keine finanziellen Einbussen.
Ich habe Felix einfach sozusagen
zum Zeitungspreis verkauft.
Einfach ohne Label-Zuschlag,
denn ich wollte ihr ja
nicht zu viel auflasten.
Ich habe ihr
etwa 60 oder 70 Fr. geschenkt.
Danke!
- Bitte. Hat sich gelohnt.
Ganz ohne Hintergedanken fand
der Schweineverkauf aber nicht statt.
Ich dachte schon von Anfang an,
dass das eine Frau ist,
die passen könnte.
Aber natürlich nicht ...
gleich voll dabei.
Das eine hat das andere ergeben.
Es musste wirklich viel stimmen,
bis wir zusammengekommen sind.
Man kann also sagen,
Felix hat diese Ehe gestiftet.
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Und auch Beats Offenheit, mir dieses
Schwein überhaupt zu verkaufen.
Das würde auch nicht jeder tun.
In dieser Hinsicht
war er sehr offen.
Ich schätze auch allgemein an ihm,
dass er extrem offen ist für Neues.
Er unterstützt mich in allem.
Felix ist eine Art Symbol
unserer Liebe.
Deshalb haben wir ihn hier verewigt.
Gell, Felix?
* Verspielte glockige Musik *
Und tschüss.
Claudia Troxler
lebt seit fünf Jahren auf dem Hof.
Anfangs arbeitete sie noch
als Verkäuferin im Detailhandel.
Als Beats Eltern sich altersbedingt
langsam aus der Landwirtschaft
zurückzogen,
übernahm sie immer mehr Aufgaben
auf dem Hof.
Und stellte so einiges auf den Kopf.
Ich denke anders,
ich betrachte die Tiere auch
aus einem anderen Blickwinkel.
Und auch die ganze Tierhaltung.
Und ich denke,
das ist auch richtig so.
Viele Menschen sollten etwas
dahinter sehen und dahinter schauen
und nicht nur mit Scheuklappen
durchs Leben gehen.
Sie hat mir schon
die Augen geöffnet.
Hatten Sie nie
ein schlechtes Gewissen,
dass Sie hier
diesen frischen Wind gebracht haben?
Nein,
ich habe kein schlechtes Gewissen.
Aber ich mache mir natürlich
schon auch Gedanken:
Kommt es gut, klappt wohl alles?
Und v.a. seinen Eltern gegenüber.
Sie haben hier alles aufgebaut,
haben ihr Herzblut
in diesen Betrieb gesteckt.
Dann komme ich und stelle alles
ein wenig auf den Kopf.
Aber schlussendlich müssen wir ja
schauen, dass es uns beiden gut geht
und dass wir hinter dem,
was wir tun, stehen können.
So wie es jetzt ist,
mit der Milch und mit den Schweinen,
stimmt es für mich persönlich nicht.
Beats Eltern wollten vor der Kamera
nicht über die Hofumstellung
der Jungen reden.
Ohne Konflikte läuft es eher selten.
Aber was ich
über die Jahre gesehen habe -
seit drei Jahren begleite ich
gewisse Familien enger -,
ist, dass die Eltern
z.T. einfach besorgt sind.
Das ist sehr schön zu sehen.
Jetzt, wo sie sehen,
dass es funktioniert und gut kommt,
sind sie sehr unterstützend,
tauchen ein und helfen.
Sie machen z.B. Parkservice
an Anlässen.
Sie nehmen ihren Teil
am ganzen Projekt wahr.
Hinteregg im Kanton Zürich:
Mit dem Hof Narr
haben Sarah Heiligtag und ihr Partner
vor sieben Jahren ihre Vision
eines friedlichen Miteinanders
von Mensch und Tier umgesetzt,
das Claudia und Beat Troxler
für ihr eigenes Projekt inspirierte.
111 gerettete ehemalige Nutztiere
leben auf dem Hof Narr.
Auf Hofführungen
sollen Besucherinnen und Besucher
zum Nachdenken angeregt werden.
Für wen oder was
ist ein Lebewesen da?
Das ist die grosse Frage,
auch bei den Menschen.
Sind wir für etwas da?
Ich glaube, wir sind in erster Linie
da, um uns selbst zu verwirklichen,
um unser Glück -
das klingt so kitschig -,
um zu finden,
was uns im Leben erfüllt.
Bei den Tieren
ist es genau dasselbe.
Sie sind dafür geboren,
sich selbst zu verwirklichen.
Hof Narr ist ein bioveganer
Landwirtschaftsbetrieb.
Produziert werden Früchte und Gemüse
für Abos und für den Direktverkauf.
Was hier angebaut wird,
landet direkt und ohne Umweg
über das Tier auf dem Teller.
Ob Tiere auf bioveganen Höfen
etwas verloren haben -
darüber wird noch debattiert.
Ich gehöre zu jenen, die sagen:
Tiere dürfen durchaus dabei sein,
man darf sie einfach nicht töten,
ihnen nicht die Kinder wegnehmen,
ihnen letztendlich
kein Leid zufügen.
Aber Tiere
dürfen durchaus dabei sein,
die in irgendeiner Form
etwas beitragen.
Einfach nicht auf Kosten
ihres Lebens oder Wohlbefindens.
Bei uns heisst das konkret -
wir haben ja einen Lebenshof
mit geretteten Tieren -,
dass wir den Dünger der Tiere
nutzen.
Der Verein Hof Narr
unterstützt Claudia und Beat Troxler
mit einem fixen Beitrag
und bei der Suche nach Paten
für ihren Lebenshof,
der jetzt auch einen Namen hat:
Lebenshof Aurelio.
Es ist Ende August -
Infotag auf dem Hof Narr.
Ich freue mich sehr,
dass ihr trotz des Wetters
den Weg hierher gefunden habt.
Das sagt schon sehr viel.
Es sind zwei
unglaublich tolle Persönlichkeiten
und ganz viele tolle
Tierpersönlichkeiten,
die dort gemeinsam
etwas angefangen haben,
bei dem ich von Anfang an gespürt
habe und es jedes Mal wieder spüre:
Das wird etwas Grosses und
es wird noch viel zu reden geben.
Ich bin Claudia Troxler,
das ist mein Mann Beat.
Wir haben in diesem Frühling/Sommer
beschlossen,
dass wir aus der konventionellen
Nutztierhaltung aussteigen wollen.
Ich bin seit 20 Jahren Vegetarierin.
Seit ich immer mehr dahinter gesehen
habe, wie die Milchwirtschaft läuft,
bin ich zur Veganerin geworden.
Ich habe Beat immer erzählt,
was ich fühle,
wenn die Tiere
in die Metzgerei gehen müssen.
Langsam hat auch er eingesehen, dass
es für ihn auch nicht mehr stimmt.
Also fingen wir an,
Alternativen zu suchen.
Wir hatten ja noch 200 Mastschweine
in einem separaten Stall.
Dort wollte ich eigentlich
schon länger etwas anderes machen.
Denn ich hatte nie richtig Freude
an den Mastschweinen.
Wir hatten einige Ideen:
Katzenhotel, Hundepension usw.
Das Ziel für die Zukunft wäre,
dass wir mit Patenschaften
die Tiere finanzieren können.
D.h.,
dass die Tiere sich selbst tragen.
Ja?
- Wie viel kostet eine Patenschaft?
Es ist unterschiedlich.
Bei uns leben ja Kühe, Schweine,
Alpakas und Hühner.
Eine Vollpatenschaft für eine Kuh
kostet 250 Fr.,
für ein Alpaka 160 Fr.,
für ein Schwein 200 Fr.
und für ein Huhn 30 Fr. pro Monat.
Danke.
Es hat mich sehr beeindruckt,
wie authentisch sie berichtet haben.
Sie liessen uns teilhaben an ihrem
Lebensweg, an dieser Entwicklung.
Und an der neuen Erkenntnis,
die sie gefunden haben.
Die Veränderung,
den Mut, das anzugehen,
die eigene Überzeugung
fortwährend zu leben,
finde ich sehr eindrücklich.
Sie machen das ziemlich mutig
und haben eine gute Atmosphäre.
Ich bin schon gespannt,
den Hof beim Tag der offenen Tür
anzuschauen.
Ich habe einen sehr guten Eindruck
und glaube,
dass sie das durchziehen werden.
Ich glaube,
dass sie mit Herzblut dabei sind.
Sie haben verstanden, dass das Tier
in der Nutztierhaltung stark leidet.
Sie können aussteigen
und etwas aufbauen, das Zukunft hat.
Unter den Hofbesuchern
sind auch Yvonne und Toni Kathriner,
die ihren Hof im zürcherischen Wald
vor drei Jahren umgestellt haben.
Wir sind beide
als Bauernkinder aufgewachsen,
haben diese Ausbildung gemacht,
haben in diesem Bereich gearbeitet.
Wenn Menschen daraus ausbrechen
und erzählen, was sie erlebt haben,
wenn sie wissen, wovon sie reden,
hat das eine sehr grosse Kraft.
Es muss niemand sagen:
"Ja, wenn du wüsstest ..."
Nein, wir wissen es eben.
Das ist schön, das ist kraftvoll.
* Akzentuierte
gezupfte Saitenklänge *
Altishofen im Kanton Luzern.
Hier steht der Schweinemastbetrieb
von Meinrad Pfister
mit hofeigener Biogasanlage.
Pfister ist Präsident
des Schweizerischen Schweinezucht-
und Schweineproduzentenverbandes.
Für diesen Film
und Tierethikerin Sarah Heiligtag
öffnet er die Türen
zu seinem Betrieb.
Die sind jetzt ca. zwei Wochen alt.
Das ist eine typische Bucht.
Pfisters 100 Muttersauen
und die 500 Mastschweine
werden nach den Richtlinien
von IP-Suisse gehalten
und gehen als Label-Fleisch
in den Verkauf.
Ich bin auf diesem Bauernhof
aufgewachsen,
hatte selbst Kaninchen.
Ich habe gelernt, diese zu
schlachten und selbst zu zerlegen.
Und mit den Schweinen später auch.
Für mich ist das Alltag,
ich bin so aufgewachsen.
Ich kann das auch abgrenzen:
Das sind Nutztiere.
Und ich möchte ihnen in der Zeit,
in der sie hier sind,
das bestmögliche Leben ermöglichen,
sodass ich wirtschaftlich
auch davon leben kann.
Dann kommt aber der Tag,
an dem das Tier zum Metzger geht.
Das grenze ich ganz klar ab.
Danach ist es ein Lebensmittel.
Dort liegt wahrscheinlich der Punkt:
Für mich gibt es keine Nutztiere,
für mich gibt es Lebewesen.
Dort liegt der Unterschied:
Für mich ist kein Tier
als Nutztier geboren.
Für mich braucht es heutzutage
auch keine Nutztiere mehr.
Deshalb habe ich ganz generell
einen Konflikt -
nicht auf diesen Betrieb bezogen.
Dürfen wir das ethisch gesehen
oder ist es an der Zeit,
einen Schritt weiterzugehen?
Was ist die Zukunft,
wie kommen wir in eine Zukunft,
in der wir
möglichst wenig Leid erzeugen?
Für mich kommt zuerst die Nachfrage.
Das Fleisch wird ja nachgefragt.
Wir produzieren das Fleisch
hier auf dem Betrieb,
nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen
und nach den wirtschaftlichen
Möglichkeiten,
mit denen wir
das Fleisch absetzen können.
50 % aller Schweineställe
sind nach Label-Richtlinien gebaut,
aber verkaufen können wir nur 30 %,
die Tendenz
ist im Moment sogar sinkend.
Das ist ein Dilemma.
Ich bin gern bereit,
noch viel mehr zu tun:
mehr Platz, mehr Streu,
alles Drum und Dran -
wenn die Nachfrage da ist.
Ich erlebe oft Bauern, mittlerweile
auch viele Schweinebauern,
die uns kontaktieren,
weil sie aus- oder umsteigen
oder etwas anderes machen wollen.
Sie sagen auch immer:
"Die Konsumenten ..."
Umgekehrt sagen die Konsumenten
immer: "Die Produzenten ..."
Und ich sage: Das ganze System
ist vielleicht irgendwie falsch.
Es sind sicher auch
die Subventionen, die Politik.
Man könnte vieles ändern,
andere Dinge unterstützen.
Es liegt weder nur am Konsumenten
noch nur am Produzenten.
Ich glaube,
es ist eine Tendenz des Menschen,
die Schuld den anderen zu geben, zu
sagen: "Die wollen und kaufen das."
Aber sie würden auch
andere Dinge kaufen.
Das sieht man jetzt
mit dem boomenden veganen Markt.
Das wird ja auch gekauft.
Viele entscheiden sich mittlerweile
wenn möglich für den veganen Burger.
Aber das Angebot muss da sein.
Diese Verantwortung
liegt ein Stück weit
bei der Konsumentin,
dem Konsumenten.
Es muss einem bewusst sein: Mit
dem Griff ins Regal entscheide ich.
* Verspielte glockige Musik *
Die Alpakas sind die neugierigsten,
nicht?- Ja.
Bettina Hersberger hat eine Teil-
patenschaft in der Höhe von 60 Fr.
für ein Stierkalb
auf dem Eichenmoos-Hof übernommen.
Dein Gotti ist da, gell?
Lenny wurde mit
deformierten Vorderfüssen geboren.
Dank Physiotherapie
mit Claudia Troxler ist er genesen.
(Lachend) Oh!
Was gibt Ihnen diese Patenschaft?
Sie gibt mir die Gewissheit,
dass Lenny ein gutes
und glückliches Leben hat.
Ich darf ihn jederzeit besuchen
und finde es schön,
hier Zeit zu verbringen.
Das Wissen, dass ich hierherkommen
und Zeit mit ihm verbringen darf.
Es freut mich einfach,
zu sehen, wie er jetzt aussieht.
Auf den ersten Fotos,
die ich von ihm bekommen habe,
konnte er nicht
auf seinen Klauen stehen.
Er musste
auf seinen Fesselgelenken gehen.
Man wusste nicht, ob es gut kommt.
Jetzt sehe ich ihn
und er steht normal auf den Beinen,
als ob nie etwas gewesen wäre.
Das ist doch Geschenk genug.
Ja, du Grosser!
Bettina Hersbergers Partner
ist Grafiker
und hat für den neuen Lebenshof
Aurelio eine Homepage gestaltet.
Für Gotteslohn.
Wenn es programmiert ist, gibt es
das Frontend - das, was man sieht -
und das Backend,
das ihr bearbeiten könnt.
Ihr geht über den Browser rein,
meldet euch an,
dann habt ihr eine Oberfläche,
über die ihr alle Bilder und Texte
ändern könnt.
Es ist super, dass du uns
so unterstützt.- Finde ich auch.
Wirklich cool!
- Klar doch.
* Entspannte Musik *
Im März dieses Jahres wurde
die letzte Kuh künstlich besamt.
Claudia Troxler und ihr Mann
rechneten damit,
dass sie noch bis Ende Jahr
melken würden.
Doch es ging alles viel schneller -
es ist Ende September.
Heute werden die Eichenmoos-Kühe
zum allerletzten Mal gemolken.
Das letzte Mal diese Handgriffe -
was ist das für ein Gefühl?
Ja ...
Eigentlich ein schönes Gefühl.
Denn man weiss, dass es
den Kühen nachher besser geht.
Man kann andere Arbeiten machen,
wir müssen gleich viel arbeiten
fürs Geld.
Man hat dann etwas anderes.
Es sind gemischte Gefühle.
Ich habe schon gerne gemolken.
Etwas Wehmut ist also auch da?
- Ein Stück weit, ja.
Für die sozialen Medien
werden die letzten Stunden
der Troxlers als Kuhmilchbauern
verewigt.
* Rhythmisches Pumpen
der Melkmaschine *
Wir sind immer noch Milchbauern.
Wir produzieren einfach keine
Kuhmilch mehr, sondern Hafermilch.
Wie ist es Ihnen zumute?
Ich freue mich mega für die Kühe,
dass sie keine Milch mehr
für Menschen produzieren müssen.
Sie sind jetzt
keine sog. Nutztiere mehr.
Und wie finden es die Kühe?
Die Kühe ...
... sind etwas frustriert,
weil es nicht mehr so gutes Futter
wie vorher gibt.
Sie bekommen keinen Mais mehr
und etwas magereres Heu,
damit sich die Milchmenge reduziert.
Das finden sie nicht so cool.
Es ist Anfang November.
Aus dem ehemaligen Schweinestall
wurde ein Laufstall
für die Eichenmoos-Kühe.
Künftig sollen hier auch hoffremde
vor dem Schlachthaus gerettete Tiere
ein Zuhause finden.
100 Besucher und potenzielle Paten
hatten sich bereits angemeldet,
aber der geplante Besuchstag musste
wegen der Pandemie abgesagt werden.
Trotzdem haben 50
der insgesamt 70 Tiere auf dem Hof
in der Zwischenzeit
Teilpaten gefunden.
Ihr Unterhalt in den neuen Stallungen
ist vorerst gesichert.
Wie ist es für Sie,
in diesem grossen Stall zu sein?
Das ist schön,
denn die Tiere haben genug Platz
und können bei der Mutter sein.
Gell, Denise?
Ich freue mich, dass ich
zu 100 % hinter dem stehen kann,
was wir jetzt tun.
Das ist mir vorher schwergefallen.
Jetzt ist es super.
Ich freue mich auch auf die Leute,
die kommen
und ihr Patentier besuchen,
auf die Hafermilchproduktion.
Ja, ich freue mich.
Es hätte ein nahtloser Übergang
von der Kuhmilch-
auf die Pflanzendrink-Produktion
werden sollen.
Das hat nicht ganz geklappt,
weil die notwendigen Maschinen
nicht geliefert wurden.
Aber heute -
mit einigen Wochen Verspätung -
sprudelt dort, wo bis vor Kurzem
die Kuhmilch geflossen ist,
der Pflanzendrink.
Hergestellt mit Wasser
aus der hofeigenen Quelle und -
ab nächstem Jahr -
mit dem hofeigenen Hafer.
Noch ist vieles improvisiert.
Doch die ersten Bestellungen sind da.
Die Troxlers
fahren die Produktion hoch.
Es braucht extrem viel Handarbeit
bei der Hafermilch, oder?
Ja,
mit dem jetzigen Produktionsablauf
ist es schon
ziemlich viel Handarbeit.
Was wiederum den Preis von 4.10 Fr.
rechtfertigt.
* Entspannte Musik *
Mit ihm hat alles angefangen:
Mastschwein Felix
hat zwei Menschen zusammengeführt,
welche die in der Landwirtschaft
vorgegebenen Pfade verlassen haben,
um ihre Vision zu leben:
die Vision eines Lebenshofes,
wo es keine Nutz- oder Haustiere mehr
gibt, sondern einfach Lebewesen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2020